all right ashley and baby dylan i love
this little surprise that we're getting
nap time
we'll wait he will make his tv debut
yes indeed
yeah
uh well he's uh too little to understand
everything we're gonna talk about so i
feel fine jumping right into where the
last episode
left off
yes let's get to it you walk into
williamsburg you light a match
let's be very clear don't attack my
husband yeah because that's something i
do not play with why are you looking at
me i'm looking at you because it was
your ass having a conversation with
ashley did you tell her what i said
don't with my family
all right
sorry i'll see y'all
i mean
you said to the camera this is not how
this was supposed to go that is not how
that was supposed to take out just not
really it was motivation for that what
did you really expect what happened
though
well honestly when i brought it to
wendy's attention i actually initially
expected wendy's to be upset with me i
didn't anticipate that she would have
all of this animosity toward giselle and
i didn't know that there was all this
underneath the surface that wendy really
thought about giselle that bubbled and
overflowed like some very molten hot
lava okay
i didn't know that what's so funny the
life you're living now is exactly god
paying you back for all the [ __ ]
you've done
so live in your mother's truth because
god
it was all really surprising to me um
and i was actually a little bit more
prepared for wendy to have a reaction
with me simply because again i was not
coming from a messy place this time and
i think she understood that um but again
it just was not what i intended for her
to be so
oh just
i don't even know the word it was like
it was yeah
it was trollish
it was wild it was absolutely wild i
mean very entertaining but i imagine
being there in person quite
alarming um let's
unpack
everything you just said looking back do
you feel at all set up by giselle
no i don't feel set up by giselle
usually when giselle and i are in the
kitchen together we both know it you
know we both have our chef hats on we
have our our our spatulas and our spoons
and we're just the cooking but this was
not that feeling you know we were
actually like sitting in the restaurant
being patrons this time not cooking up
the mess so
i i
i don't think she set me up because as
we know if giselle really wants to shade
you if she really wants to throw you
under the bus she will have absolutely
no problem doing stuff okay i was gonna
say gisele usually does the the bidding
herself she doesn't often send someone
else to take care of things she wants
done
um
i still am a little lost in this logic
of
there are rumors eddie is cheating on
wendy so she got a whole new body to
shut down the rumors to me it's more she
saw herself on tv and wanted to upgrade
herself that's where my head is at okay
i think i could see that for sure um i
think that
throughout the
episode so far we have seen that there
has been just and like with any couple
especially during this pandemic there's
just been some
rockiness between eddie and wendy
are you happy are you fulfilled you've
reached your goals no
i really don't think that it was too
much of a shot in the dark myself okay
um
do you really think gisele had wendy's
best interest in mind in bringing this
up or was it a malicious attack as wendy
is saying it is or is it somewhere in
between
like i said if gizelle really wanted to
be malicious if she really wanted to
shade eddie i guarantee you she would
have had the one-liners coming left
right and center that would have landed
dead on so i don't i'm not going to say
it was malicious um
i think wendy should know enough in this
group that if we really do want to be
malicious toward you if there are people
who want to really say underhanded
things i eat candice um then they have
no problem doing so so
i felt like it was an overreaction and i
felt like there was more to her story
not to that story but to her story than
she was letting on in that moment okay
so it's
your feeling is
something else is bubbling under wendy's
surface that this is
what's coming out and it's maybe
misdirected
yes yes uh she fired off read after read
dig after dig at gizelle if you want to
go
we could get a pocket no i need you to
all before i came on this show
we're not talking about blogging more
baby girl imagine being with a man that
consistently cheats on you all the time
and sleeps around all of baltimore and
everyone knows it but you continuously
be with this person and think he's
worthy enough to bring him around your
daughters like you know how low of a
self-esteem you have to have did that
feel like that was planned and rehearsed
to you or did it feel like oh she's just
going off and this is what's popping
into her head
well bryce let's say you're not just
gonna rattle off all of these really
hateful and cut to the white meat
remarks so quickly unless there's
something that you have been thinking
about or some other feelings that you
have been having i just don't think that
it is a natural reaction right off the
cuff to go so deep so hard so fast i
mean i left that episode in a bit of
shock i i think you left the house in a
bit of shock what did you make of
candace following you into the kitchen
to
confront you so bringing that into the
it's online leave it online then first
of all i don't believe in talking behind
each other's facts i've tried that it
never works out if you're talking about
something that you know someone is going
to hear about as soon as you can just
take it to the person and so that's what
i did
for candace to have such a harsh
reaction first of all again i don't
think her issue with me was about what i
said it was more so the other things
that she has about me that she's been
caring for the last four years and she
just was looking for an opportunity to
explode i think compacting that is the
fact that i'm still friends with monique
and how i handled the situation and
supported my friend
last year which probably does still
stink for her a little bit but for her
to use that as an opportunity and for to
be that the time that she decides to
condemn me after all the things she has
said
it was just real real golden i mean low
have mercy was big golden
and i spoke to her within the last
couple weeks and she did say
the monique thing stings the crux of her
issue is that
she came on the show as your friend and
she felt you didn't support her
in that first season
okay well
i don't know if candice recalls but she
left me high and dry as soon as she and
monique sat down in my restaurant i
didn't know that it was that she felt i
didn't support her because also she's
never actually said anything like that
to me ever like that sort of
vulnerability she's never had with me
that's one of my biggest problems with
her if she doesn't know how to just be
vulnerable be a real human just be a
person and tell me how you really feel
she hides her insecurities with insults
and i can't really be friends with
someone like that who doesn't know how
to just be frank with me and be open
unless i missed you i don't believe you
are in the drive back music video no i
mean
i
i had a baby at home
and um she didn't invite me
and i'm not surprised i have no issues
with her fulfilling her dream and doing
her thing i don't feel slighted i didn't
feel left out i was actually quite
content and happy
and probably you know had this baby
latched to me so i
i'm back you were busy living uh your
dream
yes yes the life i created to go back to
the kitchen moment what stuck out to me
is
candace says if it's on a blog leave it
online and you said to her i have never
brought anything from a [ __ ]
blog no
the fact that you would bring that into
the you just tell them what i need to
know about you
you feed it you're the cobra you're the
source
do you believe her to feed stuff to
the blog
i feel like she has done instagram lives
and she has done other things on social
media
that have lent themselves to stories
being fabricated or
um
just blown out of proportion
so while i don't necessarily think she's
a leak as in she's feeding blogs i think
that some of her actions creates more
narratives than she wants to take credit
for hey bye ashley bye thank you you've
left williamsburg but obviously the
conversation continues between wendy
gisele that whole explosion
can these two get to a place
that's okay or are you kind of bracing
for impact when reunion day comes there
is definitely no doubt that i will come
with rubber patties padding on because
it is going to be full on full throttle
as soon as you get to that reunion i
hope that andy is ready i hope that he's
got security on standby ultimately and
you know robin has expressed these
sentiments that it's just more so about
wendy just acknowledging that
she is a different person not not just
physically she is carrying herself
differently she's her choice of
conversation and dialogue is different
not in a bad way no one says it's bad
but it is different to be so different
and for no one to call it out then a i
think we'd be fake and b
we would definitely not be your friends
yeah no i we're definitely seeing a
different side her and i think the
conversation is warranted maybe the
delivery has been a little wonky
and to me that changes she's gone
through this process of being on reality
tv now she kind of knows it and she
maybe adjusted herself to things that
she thought either she wants to see more
of the viewers want to see more of like
a fourth wall thing
well that hurts me if that's the case
honestly because one of the reasons i
think
we are chosen to share our lives on this
platform is because we are who we are
because we stand so firm and walk so
much in our truth that i i get a little
bit concerned especially after one
season if a person feels that they have
to do a whole revamp just so that they
can meet the standards of
of the viewers or whoever because we're
sharing our real lives our personal
lives you have to have a strong sense of
self as soon as you start and if you
don't you'll just get chewed up
and not spit out but you'll get chewed
up and i think wendy's getting the true
right now because she really is not the
same person
did you're
letting her in on this conversation and
kind of sparking this drama with gisele
affect your relationship with wendy is
it in
did it kind of like
fall off after that i i was still really
surprised at how she chose to handle the
conversation with me
um and so that tells me that there's
potential for us to be able to have more
conversations
um but she's not really willing to
have a discussion with me that's free of
you know um
maliciousness and free of her having
this really strong wall up and i don't
know how we can ever make progress
maybe some stuff for the couch at
reunion
yeah you know those couches they work
wonders there is no doubt
the only thing messier than two boys is
me your tagline kind of gives me the
answer to this question but i'll ask
anyway how do you feel about having the
label of being a messy and a drama
starter a drama concert
um i am
not a drama starter first of all i just
ask the questions that nobody likes no
one wants to hear
and if i get my commentary i give my
commentary because just like you know
a-holes everybody has something to say
so i just share what i have to say
and for people to insinuate or perceive
that that means i'm messy well then so
be it if if me asking someone something
or if me to get to the bottom of the
real reason
something is happening if that makes me
messy then you know stamp it on my
forehead because
according to candace there's a lot of
room up there so just
put it on up there and let's keep it
moving you know
you'll wear it as a badge of honor well
someone who also seems to have a lot to
say is mia who's a bit of a rogue agent
she seems to have no allegiances to
anyone except maybe karen
yes she goes well if you're gonna be a
wheat [ __ ] then you don't belong here
she said a weak [ __ ] something along
that line i would love for you to
explain to me why the moment i left the
house you said she's a weak [ __ ]
who said that what did she say you
didn't what was it like to experience
that because it had been every time the
group was together it was like who is
this woman because she yes i mean talk
about the wonkiest game of telephone you
will ever play
she just like
she just she definitely changed how we
interact with each other and because you
know one of the
reasons that we have had arguments is
because there has been
misinterpretations or delivery of
information that's been very skewed or
just plain wrong right that has caused
so many problems i actually thought that
i thought mia would not
fit with the group but
to my surprise
one of the things i appreciate about mia
is just as much as she's messy and crazy
she's very loving and she is very
encouraging so she's kind of like that
sour patch kid you know like the
commercials like sour then sweet that is
definitely mia to a tea what i've
gathered she'll turn her sights on you
but she will own that she did it she's
not gonna like ignore the fact or try to
play like she didn't do the things she
did which i think is appreciated
yes
do her sights turn on you at any point
this season do you two get into it
well you know uh things
things can they arise so yes
they arise they arise and they rise what
i appreciate is how things
happen later and and how they play out
in the aftermath so
that's why i can say that even if we
don't necessarily always agree or we
have points of contention i do get down
with how mia handles things
afterward
you are in the crossfire of the salad
toss
yes
how unexpected was that uh exchange
between mia and candace everything is
going so smoothly and then all of a
sudden i don't know what happened it was
like a bomb went off
and literally like salad is being hurled
through the air
and then not just salads like something
breaks like some like uh dish or
something i mean flying dishes flying
salad
it was just nuts and i
literally had no idea what was going on
i i mean i was really just trying to get
a beer ultimately and everyone else was
like
i you know i just started trying to have
a good time i'm away from my kid and
you know i just want to have some beer
or something too
you'll be kind of watching back that's
the second cast trip and filling in the
gaps there
as you wait for your beer has corona not
reached out for a sponsorship yet what's
it gonna take
no corona hasn't reached out for a
sponsorship maybe down the road but i
think you know if a mom can invite and
catch a vibe every time then she should
have a little baby every now and again
um i'm a big fan of that but yeah no
corona
they haven't really reached out to me
yet maybe i haven't catch a vibe you
gotta make some merch with that i'm
actually quite drunk now from these two
beers so what is it about corona that
you love so much when did this love
affair start and why is that a drink of
choice
so completely honest i started drinking
coronas when i met michael
granted i met michael when i was 23
years old so i was you know i'd only
been drinking for two years michelle
today um and so i it was it was i didn't
really have an affinity for beer yet i
was really a tequila and wine drinker
and then after we started dating and we
would order them all the time i realized
how good they were they're just so
refreshing and not too happy and just
just so perfectly balanced
refreshing beer i'm actually salivating
at the summer right now which is i don't
know what that says about me i just i
love that beer you have chronolite
um
yes yes
you love me
[Music]